he's been looking after himself since he
was 14 years old he parted with jay-z to
create Rockefeller Records and changed
the hip-hop industry he's been involved
in businesses from clothing to films to
cars
he's Damon Dash and here are his top 10
rules for success 9 to 5s aren't good
because you look you hustle for weekend
but when you can do something that's for
yourself and your family it never feels
like work I hustle for my house fulfill
my last name I don't hustle for my first
I've learned over the years that you
know with anything you have to be
patient not five years patient or five
you know five months patient you know
you could be ten years patient if you
want you know empires aren't built
overnight you know I mean like I always
tell you buy the Great Wall was a 2000
year old plant mm your main lifetime
that is a one plan you know and getting
people to to to kind of you know do the
same have the same exact agenda for
lifetimes for generations what's crazy
so you know you have to be patient when
you want to do something significant no
matter what and a lot of time that means
you know not reaping the benefits of
something immediately
you know and that's the test I don't
think my approach on business is with
the average person would advise like
most I hear people say never put up your
own money and I'm saying put your own
money up work harder than everyone be
patient and just know that if you're
going to do something on your own you're
gonna have to feel some pain you know
you always have to have something that's
paying your bills so that whatever
you're creating can breathe so you don't
have to rush it you don't have to make
it push it to make money when it's not
ready you know I mean like you kind of
always have to have something solid and
then you that's paying your bills you
know because even as an artist to me as
a man you still have the responsibility
to take care of your woman to take care
of your children and to take care of
yourself and you know almost in that
order it's like children your woman and
then yourself you know I'm saying but
all of that should be able to be taken
care if that's a real man you know and
as an artist you can't say alright well
I'm not going to take care of my
children or take care of my woman or
even take care of myself well to protect
my artistry then that's not artistry to
me that's just being lazy you know I'm
saying I think as an artist you have to
fight for that artistry you know I'm
saying like you have to figure out how
to pay your bills so that the artists we
can breathe you know what I mean and it
also you know you get taught you feel
like a real man have you ever watched a
James Bond movie before it doesn't look
like he's losing at some point and then
he wins or Batman or Iron Man or any
superhero there has to be some diversity
for you to you know overcome to win it
can't be a champ unless you uh you know
are in a place where you look like
you're going to lose and then you win
the pain that's going to come with being
independent you have to embrace it
because it's going to happen and also
know that the more successful you get
the more problems you're going to have
the more not you're gonna have down time
being a boss does not mean smooth
sailing it means having the ability to
care about other people before yourself
and to untie problems on time knots
that's all it is there's it's not
business if there's not problem there's
nothing good without struggle it just
doesn't happen and all my experiences
there hasn't been one thing that's been
successful without me feeling some pain
before it was successful so now when
there is pain I embrace it you know I've
been embracing it I Maji about it
because I know that must mean that if
I'm cool that you know what awaits me
it's the darkest before the dawn
I don't want it like sound corny but
that's really what that's what has to
happen I'm always going to play fair
I mean like I don't believe in doing
anything unless it's fair because I
believe there's always karmic
repercussions from doing things unfair
so what could appear to be a win or
something that appears to be a fast you
know fast money and I know in the long
run I'm going to suffer but you know
it's always a test quick anything quick
as a test you know I can get it quick if
I don't have to cheat but if it you know
if I got a cheat to get it fast
I don't want it my parents haven't
bought me clothes since I was about 14
my parents haven't I haven't had nobody
bought me nothing let's say that no
one's taking care of me since I was 14
years old and I didn't want nobody
taking care of me because they couldn't
what they was trying to buy me I wasn't
trying to win taste talent and work
ethic you know I mean and all of it I
need all of it you know taste talent
workout fish you know well perspective
so when I interview or my even when my
the people I work with find more talent
they have to bring me I have to get a
mixtape from them can't even know what
music they're listening to because taste
of music tells a lot about a person
it really does um I got to know who the
best their favorite designer is what's
the last book they read favorite artist
and it's funny but sometimes you know
you get those the answers are hilarious
but people be trying they don't have you
know but you know you honestly have to
have you're like I look for all your
senses to be activated you know I mean
like I need you have good taste in music
I need your work ethic I need you to be
a good person I need you have a good
taste in clothes you know I need to be
at you need to be able to be savvy and
more than just one thing like everyone
that my staff can do like there's not
one job that anyone does in my staff I
make a regular business that doesn't
touch pop culture doesn't make history
then to some people that could be
considered going backwards that's not a
pressure for me because I could care
less what people think and I don't think
there's anything about my career where
you would think I did it for someone
else I'm just constantly trying to
impress myself like I've accomplished
you know relatively speaking a lot of
things and because of that I've been
able to do exactly what inspires but
everyone has the ability
take care of themselves you can always
be a hunter you can always eat the food
you kill it's just about how lazy you
are you know there's a theory it's all
about your effort thank you guys so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed my
question of the day for you is do you
agree with Damon - that you need to put
up your own money to be an entrepreneur
leave a comment below I'm curious to see
what you think now I made this video
because Jose Cruz asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile leave a comment
underneath and I'll see what I can do if
you like this video and you want to see
more don't forget to subscribe to the
newsletter and the channel have a great
day continue to believe and I hope
you'll join me again tomorrow at 7 a.m.
Eastern for another video to help you
start your day on the right foot